i appreciate you talking to me about
this i love this show on two levels it
has the nostalgia factor for me from
reading the books when i was younger and
it also proves that good stories and
good characters are universal no matter
your age
so what has it meant to you guys to get
to be a part of the babysitter's club
what's the coolest thing about being a
part of this world and doing this show
it's
yeah maybe it's your first time it's so
great um i know that mallory and jesse
loved it but annae and i also loved it
um because we got to just spend time
with those girls every day
and it was just it was a great
experience something that i've never
done so it was great yeah i'm so glad
that we got to bring these characters to
life
because like you said like the nostalgia
factor a lot of people have read these
books growing up and i'm so glad that we
can portray these characters on screen
and it's so cool to see everyone saying
like oh jesse was my favorite character
uh from the book series i can't wait to
see her in season two it's
i'm so happy to bring the character to
life
everybody
came back to this show and you guys you
know get added as members of the
babysitter's club this season so
were there nerves about
joining in that way
what reassured you
you know during your first day on set
i think that having a nay there was a
great
um
kind of like a
thing to bring my nerves down just
because we had both you know the other
cast had been shooting for many months
before us so when we came we were kind
of scared that we would you know not fit
in
um
so having an a there was was great to
just do it with someone and you know the
girls were welcoming so
yeah
season one like vivian said i was so
nervous coming on to set because all the
other girls knew each other already i i
felt a lot like jesse and mallory when
they joined the club because
um it's like i knew they were gonna be
nice but it's like are we gonna fit in
are we gonna not but just like jessie
and mallory we all the girls welcome
welcomed us in so much and they're our
best friends so coming on to film season
two was great and because we already
knew them all so well we've been texting
and facetiming for
months what does it mean to the
characters to be included as new
additions to the club what does it mean
to them to be able to take this
responsibility on
um jesse and mallory really look up to
the rest of the bsc um and in season one
you can see them say like they're like
world famous they're
valerie look out to them like they're
like celebrities so now that they're in
the club it's really surreal to them to
be in the club with like their idols
yeah jessie mallory are pretty star
struck
mallory definitely expresses it
a bit more but um
so i'm excited for the viewers to see
that what do you guys most enjoy about
working with this cast you get to do a
lot of big ensemble scenes together
what's the fun in getting to do those
and are they just really chaotic and
crazy
yeah i mean we're all
we're all best friends so we're all
super comfortable comfortable with each
other
so um the group scenes that we had in
claudia's room were definitely
some of my favorites um
we would you know
lunchtime during those days where we
would like do those scenes was always
the best because we would always sit
outside and kind of like a circle and
eat our lunch and talk and those are
some of my favorite days
yeah the scenes with all seven of us all
some seven of us were my favorite
because
i just love filming scenes with all of
us it did get a little crazy sometimes
because there were like seven teenage
girls on set all at once um and like
vivian said lunches were so fun um
especially towards towards the end of
filming we um like sat in the parking
lot and we like laid down blankets and
our coats and we all sat and ate lunch
together
what do you most love about your
character and what quality of theirs do
you wish you had yourself
um
i love my character because i love how
driven jessie is and her passion for
dance
um jessie's such a talented ballerina
and even though i play her um i wish you
know what i really wish i had her ballet
studio her ballet studio is so cool it
was one of my favorite sets to be on
because
oh my gosh jessie's so lucky that her
parents build that um ballet studio for
her and i'm def i definitely wish i had
that in my house
yeah um for me
um
mallory's siblings but i think they'd be
kind of cool it would be a little
chaotic um just because of you know she
has so many but i think having a good
variety of siblings would be fun because
i only have one in real life so
any i have to say i've been a dancer
since i was four and so i
really connect to jesse in that way and
i also would love to have had her whole
dance studio going on in my house but
what do you love about getting to
explore that side of her is there
anything that you did to prepare for
you know her dance ability
yeah um i've been doing ballet since i
was two years old so i would say i've
kind of been preparing my whole life for
this part but
even when i was in canada i would join
zoom classes with my ballet coach who
lives in london and i would just do my
ballet classes every morning and when i
didn't have time to do that i would do
ballet youtube videos so i could really
be prepared for this part because dance
is such a big part of jessie's life and
the dance scenes were definitely some of
my favorite scenes to film besides the
meetings
did you guys
feel like did you have moments that you
really sort of felt like you connected
to the character when things really
clicked when you really had an
understanding of who they were
definitely um at the beginning
um it was kind of hard to
develop
mallory as a character
so at the beginning i had to really
think
about how mallory would
act in the scene or act in the situation
or say this line because mallory and i
differ in a lot of ways and so
at the end of season two i was able to
read a line and just immediately know
how mallory would say it
and how she would act in that scene so
that was really fun for me to see how
her character development went
yeah jessie was such a fun character to
play because she's a lot like me
so
i think um jessie this season she really
struggles with her confidence and she
pushes herself to always try to be the
best and she puts a lot of pressure on
herself
and i honestly relate to that with her
because with like acting and dancing
there's a lot of pressure
um and
jesse taught me that you know i'm just a
kid and i just have to just be myself
and i don't have to worry about the
future too much and i just have to live
life in the moment
i love the message that comes through
with the season in the episode with the
kid who's famous on social media about
how sometimes you just have to be a kid
and enjoy kid things and not have that
added stress and pressure
do you guys feel like you find a balance
between living your lives using social
media
also getting to be a kid but working in
an adult world do you feel like you
really sort of found a sense of that
balance or is it something you're always
working on
yeah i think that i'm still working on
it now i mean it's very different than a
lot of what my friends at home have to
deal with
i'm pretty lucky to have a good
you know to have the
cast be around my age so if i need any
help i can just come and talk to them
um but it definitely is a different
life that the cast is living and being a
child and you know working on this show
but i think we've all found our ways to
manage it
yeah um
balancing acting in school and just
being a normal kid is never something
that you can fully master i've been
doing it since i was five and i still
haven't really perfected it and
sometimes um it does get kind of
stressful sometimes but i just take a
step back and realize
why i'm doing in the first place i'm
doing it because i love to act and even
though it can get stressful um balancing
school and acting at the same time
i just make sure to push through because
i love to i love to act and that is
really my passion so
well you guys are great in this you're
perfect in this character everybody
isn't so perfect in all their roles i i
love watching you all together
especially in those big scenes it's so
much fun so i appreciate you talking to
me about this season it's such a great
season
thank you